les vacances d'été commencent
officiellement ce mardi à 5 juillet pour
les écoliers deux mois de vacances pour
se reposer avant la rentrée des classes
on pourrait penser que c'est un peu le
plus beau jour de l'année pour les
écoliers et leurs professeurs n'est pas
forcément certains regrettent est déjà
les bancs de l'école
sephora namani et fanny bourdillon son
talent à la sortie de l'école primaire à
rimbaud à montigny le bretonneux
regardez et écoutez là beaucoup
d'émotion de la part des cm2 parce
qu'ils vont ne pas se retrouver à la
rentrée de 6e et surtout parce qu'ils
quittent l'école rabot mais c'est
toujours un grand une grande émotion
pour eux que de quitter l'école qu'ils
ont fréquentés pendant un certain nombre
d'années
c'est un jour comme un autre je suis
triste parce que c'est une année qui se
termine voilà j'étais contente de sa
maîtresse du malpas ocp donc c'est
vraiment la fin de la maternelle un peu
triste mais mais je suis quand même
contente pas de changer de classe comme
ça c'est des élèves que je quitte
toujours avec regrets oui est bon ils
vont manquer un petit peu forcément et
après je vais les retrouver puisqu'ils
seront en grande section donc je les
croise ray encore mais c'est toujours un
peu émouvant de perdre sa classe parce
qu'on les a gardées un an donc sont pas
mes enfants mais ce sont des enfants que
j'ai fréquenté un an